dude i just had a dream that
you guys
more heat on mine today someone [ __ ]
with mine man
i think it's a conspiracy theory who
[ __ ] with my horn bro it's not a
horn i'm out of town i'm out of town on
the
road for a little bit i come back
[Music]
you got that low t bro you got that low
testosterone in your horn dude it was
it was powerful and i felt you know what
hit it one more time no i think it heats
up
ah it still didn't very
sad man you know what's not sad yeah
birthday bro
thanks your birthday brother appreciate
it cheers dude happy birthday man
don't [ __ ] touch me even on your
birthday bro
don't touch me i will never touch you
and i wish they would put a little wall
right here too i've asked for it
multiple times i tell trump to build
that one yeah good thing i can barely
hear your little buzzer anymore oh
god damn it it's my birthday man you uh
how you feel
i don't have no idea if someone came up
to me and was like hey you know theo's
52 years old that's cool then someone
came out was like you know theo's
20 years old i'm like that's cool too i
have no idea oh
dude well you ate you're like a black
dude i have no idea
i have no idea dude there's a black
asian baby i heard you can't tell if
it's like two months old or
70 years old yep that's how they roll
that's a new thing agents too like how
would you think cat is oh who knows
she's 14 she's 73 or 14 hundreds
exactly from any time period dude 16th
century dynasty check
does she have a samurai sword i don't
know definite dynasty she has a long
coat on mm
yep i don't know cat gave me some nice
donuts though today thank you cat dude
inspired my outfit today because i want
to look like a cupcake for your birthday
really suit birthday
suit there's a picture okay and
yesterday was your birthday
we put a picture of you up yesterday
with those care bear tattoos on your
back
dude that boy is super
thick gravy veins right
oh yeah that guy and that's you brennan
that's you
at uh 11 years old
dude he is so thick bro he is
so thick brendan was raised in a tattoo
yard
he's way smaller than i am a lot of free
ink hitting the airwaves oh
yeah that boy doesn't miss a weight he
does oh
that guy's lifted them all the way
man you can see his uh his shoulders are
jacked i have no idea how his hopes up
that dude is strong bro his shoulders
are jacked from trying to carry his
dreams
and that's why it's working out and that
everybody knows that your alternate uh
that's your alternate email account he's
better looking than i am though
well he's definitely better looking
really i didn't look at him like that
really yeah i don't know yeah really
100 he seems like a nice guy yeah he
definitely knows his way around the
weight room
yeah guy has a lot of wisdom to drop on
people he hikes a lot
uh does he yeah or does he just stay in
the weight room and eat
no he stops somewhere to take that
picture on the side of the road
somewhere probably oh that's a good
point that's a good point he's
he's a dying piece man but happy
birthday man too bad it's not your
birthday
i know my day late bro well day late
dude
who knows when your birthday is dude
we're some pisces babies aren't we
we aren't in pisces babies
bro
no you know we are some march babies our
parents pumped in the same month bro
pretty awesome right no they did look at
us man two pisces
yeah don't look at us and not should we
get in some current events let's get
into anything else dude
brennan's definitely the kind of guy
that when you say it's your birthday he
tells you in his birthday
that's definitely the truth well mine
dude whatever it was yesterday though
yeah yesterday's over
same basic birthdays like what time were
you born huh
10 40 p.m 10 40 p.m yep all right i was
born at midnight so it's like
right before midnight so we could have
been born on the same day who was born
at [ __ ]
midnight dude i was banned because i'm a
gremlin are you slytherin bro
who was born at midnight your birthday's
over man all all the past is the past
man do you like birthdays or you get sad
on birthdays oh i think it's kind of a
50 50. i don't really
these days you have to respond respond
sorry
yeah i uh i took a [ __ ] word out of
here again
yeah welcome to ct welcome to ct the
population
you and me it's kind of nice it's kind
of cool you get away with a
ton of [ __ ] yeah you can be racist
sometimes everyone's like yeah you got
punched in the face
yeah what else you got [ __ ] i don't know
what we're talking about man oh your
birthday you get sad on it i usually get
sad on my birthday
you do yeah i don't know why um my
birthday was great
no listen if [ __ ] l.a had a parade
for my birthday i'd still be sad at the
end of the night i don't know why
since i was a kid it's not your birthday
right but it is though you know
but it is a birthday month bro pisces
brother get the [ __ ] out of here
get out of here dude icy brothers dude
whoa
bro i think that pink sweater has
something it has a little bit of
leftover whoever you borrowed it from in
it dude you're acting a little
tender of it you're not like a pisces
bro no you're not you're a kid you have
good birthdays
oh yeah dude somebody cost you a cactus
for your birthday i got bit by a dog
i got bit by dogs on one birthday and
cats on another birthday got attacked by
two cats
so it's a good time well it's just
different times there's more stray
animals back then and things were
different the candles really got them
all excited if they had a lot of animals
in your area
but i remember this dude these days you
have to reply to so many texts and stuff
like that it's a lot of like
electronic work on your birthday i feel
like you know i feel like real friends i
mean
unless you're a real real close friend
you can text happy birthday i knew we're
gonna see each other say happy birthday
um but in general yeah i'm good man you
don't need to really text me especially
on christmas don't take it on christmas
yeah thanksgiving [ __ ] off you know what
i'm saying yeah like be cool man
and then don't get mad if i don't take
you back yeah happy thanksgiving
somebody sent you that what are you
happy thanksgiving
you have no one else to text what the
[ __ ] yeah dude happy fourth of july get
the [ __ ] out my friend yeah
watch go watch the lions god get up
thank giving get a friend yeah bro
let's go all right first one looks like
the saddest kid at a birthday party
right now
wow nick does look like that he looks
like super sad he's dressed like where's
waldo that's a great call
he's just like where's waldo and got
picked last on the dodgeball team
i got way more stripes than waldo on
right gang bruh
kang gang the only person that wore the
hat
trying to be faster it's not my birthday
bro he's doing good huh yeah
i know it's not your birthday it's not
my birthday but his birthday month for
parties
don't touch me pisces brother [ __ ]
touch party i see brothers dude we're
like two fish
no we're not so much bro two fish i'm a
shark and you're a sick salmon nope
it's like we were connected at the head
at one point yeah you know those two
kids that are always connected were like
that those aren't
separated but you were older i was like
two and you were
17. all right what else you got nick
first one reality tv star and mother of
honey boo boo
mama june was addressed on drug charges
in alabama i love her
she was picked up in a alabama gas
station and police found
crack cocaine a needle and a pipe in her
car yeah i want some money on this bet
but some of the cars in alabama if you
get a used car in alabama there's
definitely drug paraphernalia in it you
can't
you know it's like there's a tire iron
and then like oh what's that little tire
iron with crack in it oh why is there a
dead body in the back and it just comes
with chevy's
yeah so it's there's a lot of it depends
on what you get down there
you know so i don't want to judge her
yet was it was a chrysler sebring
because those we know have issues yeah
yeah there's always
always have drug paraphernalia you have
the top down there's drugs in there
also did she put all the weight back on
because remember it went from she went
from i think the show was from hot to
not
she lost a shitload of weight you know
but there's nothing to do about your
faith but she lost a ton of weight
and then she was doing well right i i
didn't i never followed her much but the
show was from not to hot
and she's went back to not i know she
stays skinny i saw her
okay she looked nice she saw some bf
maybe she felt pressured to have to stay
skinny and sometimes at a certain point
it's like you'll do anything crack could
do that though
crap go help me fit into a [ __ ]
bathing suit that's for sure dude if
you're having trouble at the beach just
give you the runs
buy a couple rocks dude yeah it gives
you everything damn i kind of want to
try something it's trying to shut a few
you know dude it gives you everything
and i don't know if she lost the weight
but the kid
picked it up i don't know if you've seen
booboo yeah booboo you can trade the
weight of
that family you know what you carry the
weight now that's a new show called
weight swap
honey picking up a goddamn book you ever
seen her on that show jesus christ yeah
right
she knows about two of the vowels bro
she definitely nobody gave her all she
knows more than two rivers i'll give her
that
oh yeah i bet she does but she's a
beautiful little girl you know she quit
pageanting
and did she give that up yeah that's a
shame she had a real future i think she
quit pageanting and she's just kind of
just being around the way just kind of
an around-the-way chick i heard she has
a boyfriend
the honey boo boo yeah the the little
one yeah she's a boyfriend yeah cause
she's like 13
now is she how old is she 13.
what else we got the first poster for
the movie once upon a time in hollywood
starring brad pitt
and leonard leonardo dicaprio dropped
this week it's the movie that's going to
follow
an actor and his stunt man in 1969
hollywood during the charles manson
murders
and here's this movie that's my dick
card bro i love the charles manson stuff
i don't like that people are murdered
i like that old hollywood stuff the cult
stuff
i followed this charles mans stuff way
too close have i driven through to pay
canyon and look at some of the places
where he's lived yeah i have really have
i driven past the murder sites
maybe i have why yeah i'm not into it
bro so i'm into this [ __ ]
you're into that huh i think every now
and then if somebody in the hollywood
hills has to get murdered
so be it yeah that's kind of where i'm
from you know like you take that chance
you know if you're gonna be real fancy
sometimes you gotta catch a slug you
know
yeah i have no problems with it that
charles manson story is
amazing i just don't know why are there
so many uh
people in this movie that's what seems
bizarre to me there's so many famous
exact
tyler perry movies well that always
feels so forced they did that
i don't know if it was american gangster
what was the one that won all those
awards one year but it was just garbage
but
jennifer there's so many lewis senators
yeah i know you're talking about
jennifer
uh that people everybody liked and then
everybody did it what was that girl's
name she's silver lining his playbook
yeah he's hot
but what america is [ __ ] hustle
cooper malcolm x martin luther king had
so many people yeah it was like how much
[ __ ] can we put in here the same
michael jackson yeah just whatever dude
dude it had uh
harriet tubman in the beginning like
what the [ __ ]
what is going on dude it had uh the
wright brothers and the uh
you know played airline pilots in it oh
luke perry's in this
charles manson movie right yes wow his
final uh his final role
quentin tarantino directed so manson
ain't done yet dude manson said he would
get one more i guess it was luke perry
dude
you know yeah somehow look i'll tell you
this if he wasn't in the movie he might
still be alive
conspiracy theory dude might be honest
call eddie bravo bro pull him up yeah
he'll confirm
he got too into his role like heath
ledger yeah end up dead there you go
oh wow you got to stay on the cusp of
your roll dude you can't get too deep
you know
like you don't [ __ ] with the manson
stuff stay on the cusp of roll don't be
a bread stick baby
what else we got there you mentioned
slytherin earlier uh
harry potter author jk rowling said in
an interview recently that elvis
dumbledore
and fellow fictional character from the
world of harry potter gellert
grindelwald had an intense sexual
relationship that was not written about
how's this news how the [ __ ] is this
news i'm not into harry potter but i
listen i respect what she's done went
from nothing to a jagillionaire
great good for you kids and twix and
what the [ __ ] they do
magic right but also i assume they're
[ __ ]
like kermit the frog and miss piggy they
[ __ ]
we know this man gonzo sucking off burt
and ernie we know this
do you think that the big news was
gellert was a um it was a male male
relationship
that was not spoken about so people and
ernie bert and ernie are gay as [ __ ]
yeah burt and ernie bengay jk so come up
with something new yeah
be original j.k simmons here's my thing
jk rowling's always start trying to
raise hell i think and she seems to be
pub obsessed with publicity every week
she's saying you know
you know larry griswold was a [ __ ]
serpent or somebody
you know had [ __ ] you know um mr
magard icardi
had [ __ ] fish living in his eyes or
whatever it's always some kind of [ __ ]
or
she's trying to make headlines yeah you
gotta ride that [ __ ]
universal [ __ ] man yeah pipe down yeah
look if it wasn't written about then it
didn't [ __ ] happen that's just you
thinking about [ __ ] you nut case
okay shout out to burton yeah it was
unwritten well then it ain't [ __ ]
because you're the writer i can't
[ __ ] write what do you mean
written you're the writer
this ain't news [ __ ] draw a sketch jk
yeah put a finger paint on [ __ ] yeah
dude and also
here's the thing so aggressive jk
rowling if you're going to do some
sexual stuff
do it with hermione granger boy you know
what i'm saying
i'd put it in here bro don't touch me
i'd put it in hermione son
sir but all this other [ __ ] so and so
was gay who ain't gay y'all are out
there [ __ ] doing spells and wizards
everybody's [ __ ] gay
in the magic world everybody's sucking
dude yeah y'all drove a shopping cart
into an embankment and woke up and
[ __ ] narnia brother
it's the dark arts everybody's coming
right that's calm country yeah you don't
do magic without
coming while you do magic bro you think
i'll get david blaine
yeah it comes non-stop dude you think
i'm gonna turn a snake into a [ __ ]
uh quidditch stick and not [ __ ] jerk
off once you're out of your mind
god yeah oh [ __ ] do you think i'm gonna
ride a magic carp and not bust
nuts on the way come on bro dude
everybody's gay in there i'm surprised
there's like a 40
chance of seed in the air every day then
i want in what else we got jesus
all right last current event because i
know theo's uh
trying to get into some gaming uh in an
espn article detailing the strife in the
philadelphia phillies locker room last
season
it was revealed that carlos santana
smashed a tv in the clubhouse with a
baseball
bat because teammates were playing
fortnite during games what the [ __ ] is
he doing there
was he touring the the baseball player
not the uh
oh my legendary guitars yeah i saw
santana in tucson once
how was he out there by the fairgrounds
he was okay we want to talk about
someone who overcame down syndrome just
keeps doing it man
that guy all he plays the guitar no
singing
[Music]
yeah him and los lobos they're always
performing they're performing in every
city every night
sometimes i would not go to his concert
there's no singing yeah we're good man
it's just him on the guitar
yeah good for him man come over that's
him i think isn't it
buddy yeah he probably [ __ ] went
crazy because he was at a baseball game
bro you showed up at the wrong stadium
to perform dude
yeah no one's paying attention playing
their video games and started breaking
[ __ ]
time to pay the abuse dude i'm burning
up man
are you yeah do you have a fever no i
mean it's hot out sting that
sting a fever for sure but also sting
wearing sweatshirts get a shirt bro
everyone needs shirts yeah every day i
need a shirt but i need something that's
easy to find it's comfortable looks
great fits perfect
don't go looking for shirts have shirts
look for you
shopping for shirts should be as simple
as shopping for milk man dude are you
talking about twillery yeah
i knew it twitter all the kids are
talking about it dude and we're the kids
twillery shirts are comfortable easy to
care for
look great and fit perfectly you get a
100
shirt for 55 when you buy in bulk wow
and it's always free shipping in the us
and it's always free returns
they are slimming they are tailored fit
just for you
so you always look your best you can
wear them tucked untucked
you could tie them in that little thing
that shows you're down to pot sure
man maybe go on a happy hour untuck it
work
tuck it yeah they got it all bro they
got it all
live your life why not smart casual just
got smarter yup classic shirting that's
tailored for untucked greatness go ahead
unwind unplug most importantly untuck
life's too short to be tucked in oh
what's wrong with him is he sick
does he have constipations is he nervous
untuck untuck it baby and guess what
you guys the kingston listeners get 25
off their first shirt
by going to twillery.com
k-a-t-s that's t-w-i-l-l-o-r-y
dot com slash k-a-t-s and enter promo
code cats at checkout yep
i opened mine today because it was my
birthday and i
i i actually should have worn it i'd
already planned to wear this but next
time i'll wear my tillery i'm going to
wear mine too oh really
yeah let's have a twillow spicy bros oh
no tell me where they can get
king and the sting listeners can get 25
off their first
shirt order by going to twillery.com
k-a-t-s and entering promo code k-a-t-s
at checkout that's t-w-i-l-l-o-r-y dot
com
slash k-a-t-s someone got to pay for
theo's haircut
next up we have debate club
and the first one the first announcement
i need conspiracy who [ __ ] am i horn
nick was it you
i i love that [ __ ] my horn bro
favorite part of the show
it sounds like someone sucked on the
hole jesus christ
bro go back to your birthday dude you
were so much nicer i bet
let's get into it yesterday i know bro
it's the past
i hear that heat and look at that light
on mine i didn't know you had a light
first debate club topic comes from
tristan robinson
tristan thompson tr let's hit it yo what
up brennan
i got a debate club question for you who
do you think i wanted to fight in their
prime
chuck norris or jean glad fan damn
all right gang gang buzz oh got them
cheeky cheeky's out
showing that butt at the end there boy
trent what's his name trent rasner
tristan robinson tristan robinson
tristan fletcher cheeks bro
where's he from he didn't say um yeah
you don't say after you show your ass to
somebody over video yeah i don't tell
where you're from i like that movie yeah
you mooned us bro
yeah dude a flat ass moon i like that
flattered that's that flat earth moon i
said eddie bravo that dude he's got two
eddie bravos in the back of his pants
two flat cheeks uh what was the question
oh chocolate or uh chuckle adele chuck
norris
john claude van damme go ahead bro oh i
have to go on this one
i will say uh chuck norris
because chuck norris is the kind of man
he look you know he's like a step daddy
that also can fight
and fight at a high level you know
and he can kind of be in any world chuck
norris can
um you can see him one time in like a oh
he's in a suit oh he's on a tractor oh
he's
you know selling insurance you know he's
in a western yeah he's a claims adjuster
he's in a western you know he's banging
suzanne summers he's on the tony
gazelle freestyler you know what i'm
saying you're right he can [ __ ]
attack from anywhere
whereas jean-claude i think is a little
bit more limited you know
john cloud has that does the splits in
his underwear
oh he's trying to fake tans always
trying to [ __ ] you're like too pretty
yeah then had the coke habit you know
what i'm saying like
you're a martial artist bro chuck norris
don't even drink or do coke that's true
and you know what he gets high off of
kicking ass so i'm picking that dude bro
chuck norris all day he's a
you know he's i think he's a legit black
belt in jiu jitsu john claude van damme
he says he had some fights but it's not
documented
at all a lot he's a fake frank dukes bro
yeah he might
go better actor john clubbin damn
bro lionheart bloodsport kickboxing
cyborg dude when i was growing up
bloodsport was the only movie they had i
remember we go to the movie store
they had this place called pat's video
and they had shrimp and movies
and we go there oh get a [ __ ] pound
uh no peel and eat all right we go get a
pound of shrimp and a [ __ ]
and but the only movie they had one time
they had seven copies of [ __ ]
bloodsport
you're damn right they did that that's
the ugly movie one of the greatest
movies of all time
okay usa yeah and john clyde dude now
here's another thing though
he also is a senior citizen male model
and a lot of men can't even do that so
that's
cool but when you're when your best
thing is uh the splits
you're missing out on life bro like all
he does is the splits everywhere that's
true actually he's the mayor of uh
marina del rey too i used to live there
and see the man
you're the biggest jean-claude van damme
fan of all time now how big is he when
you see him
not a big man not a big man at all
that's the other reason i take
uh middle sized man you're bigger than
he is
wow yeah i mean your shoulders are
skinnier but yeah yeah but that's
because i had a fever recently
um um okay chuck norris all day
what's what's people saying 63 say
chuck norris chuck norris that's what's
up kang gang
they know what's up buzz buzz all right
next
up for debate club comes from william
juice
double j from scottsdale here juicy
juice
juice on that test 200. boy what's up
brandon
what's up theo william just here coming
to you live from
the charlotte airport heading home to
beautiful scottsdale arizona
and i got a debate club for you would
you rather have
the scrumptious chick-fil-a
or the delicious
in-n-out burger guy love you guys
out there yeah he's obviously drug mule
and some [ __ ] deca right there willie
juice they call him around the [ __ ]
gym and i'll say this i'll be in phoenix
arizona next weekend
and stand up so i had to say that
but this is a good question is it though
because
i think i'm gonna take some heat
especially from the cali fans i think
in-n-out is so
overrated dude chick-fil-a you cannot go
to chick-fil-a and it's not
cronkified i mean it is packed
oh yeah all sorts of people the what
they put on that chicken i have no idea
and you know what it's also limited go
on a sunday no one's open yeah you gotta
wait bro it's limited edition apple
fries
oh dude dude my mouth is watering and
you can
get through everything have you ever
done that no oh my god
dude today it's your birthday [ __ ]
party
hey you ever uh got just been in the
mall and then got the sample of chicken
i dare you not to buy a whole [ __ ]
sandwich after that you do the [ __ ]
u-turn bro it's so good i'll buy eggs
i'll buy a dozen eggs after i eat it bro
that's how [ __ ] good chick-fil-a
is dude and also the people that work at
chick-fil-a a lot of times if you're in
the atlanta airport
a lot of [ __ ] rappers and bootleg
rappers work there so you don't [ __ ]
cd
they'll [ __ ] put that [ __ ] put
that uh chicken with the pickle
on a [ __ ] mixtape dude yeah two
mixtapes
that's your sandwich that's what i want
you say you want the remix that's what
you get
bite into that [ __ ] baseline they got
real [ __ ] over there
man dude that's the other thing i don't
like about in and out is the secret menu
that [ __ ] pisses me off with animal
style or this style
like put it on the menu bro bro wendy's
is so much better i think
even than in and out in and out is just
a bunch of [ __ ] lettuce bro it's like
oh hey
how much lettuce can we put on here and
still get the bun to look like it's on
the top
let's put it in a slice of beef and a
lot of the sandwiches look racist they
put that little white helmet on them
that little white bag
uh i think you think of white castle no
in and out man they put it in like that
white kind of half
oh box yeah no it's not a box it's like
a little oh yeah like the white
pouch yeah it's like a clue clans uh
it's like
oh they put it in the white hood they
put in that white hood
thing i didn't think about it bro bro
that burger is looking for brothers in
your neighborhood and that [ __ ] needs to
stop
yeah and they're not looking to play
basketball yeah here's the other thing
too
here's the different here's the other
thing you got to think about chick-fil-a
little [ __ ] up but they do have
standards yeah i heard you came and
worked there if you have tattoos
yep you got to be religious yep you got
to know the lord boy
you got to be married yeah it can be no
single mom trying to
fillet my chicken uh-uh dude you can't
have any condoms in your pocket bro they
want people that are just
doing actual real sex god's work which
is
making delicious chicken and making
delicious babies dude yeah you can't
even think about sucking dick making my
fries
yeah i don't know what you're talking
about but i'm gonna say uh
i'm gonna say chick-fil-a chick-fil-a
all day
let's see what the fans said dude these
are the oh [ __ ] that was
way closer than i thought though a lot
of clothes i thought
and let's go abroad real quick and find
out cat what do people eat and uh what
do what do
other people like panda express no uh
well
in vietnam they like jolly b and kfc
there you go
oh kfc is huge yeah but uh
mcdonald's probably worldwide yeah
they have fried chicken really good
fried chicken actually spaghetti or
fried chicken
they have it's a combo so instead of
like mashed potatoes you can get
spaghetti that's disgusting
okay and filipino spaghetti is slightly
sweeter
[Music]
now i'm in god dude that sounds so good
bro
some [ __ ] agave on some vermicelli
son i'm gonna
sound nice i'm [ __ ] woke son smoked
penne with some sugar on top
all right the next one comes from stuart
watson
oh yeah this guy sounds like he's
definitely done some things to women
they didn't want
all right what up bee sting and wreck
king
gang gang skeet skeet this is dr swanson
here coming to you with a debate
question
would you rather have a penis that's the
size of a nipple
or nipples that are the size of penises
debate buzz buzz that dude probably has
some big ass nipples i think stu watt is
[ __ ] coming in hot there with that
[ __ ] rapunzel too so i think he's on
the
run it looks like he's on the run yeah
they call it the lamb out there
yep yep yep uh
listen if you got them big old [ __ ]
pepperoni nipples that hang deep too
you can't yeah think about it you can't
wear [ __ ] right like no clothes
done yeah you just look like an [ __ ]
you wear baggy [ __ ] all the time
or you gotta dress your nipples up all
the time it's exhausting
but would you rather have so if you had
weiner nipples you'd have big wieners
out here
i know we you can't milk well you can't
really milk a man's wieners like
i'm not gonna bust with my tits oh i
would what are you gonna do just have
them there
we just wanna get titty [ __ ] who cares
yeah man
what i think it'd be fun it's your
birthday bro no not by a man
by a woman well no woman's titty [ __ ]
you bro well some woman could just do
sex with you by your
chest you know oh like squeeze them
together with her tits
no or just ride one of your nipples oh i
see what they're saying jesus god dang
bro be more clear bro how okay
i don't know i mean you really
would be less blurry dog dude
you're blurry right dude no how am i
blurry
i'm talking about titty [ __ ] i don't
know what you're talking about
but these things are gone it's wieners
man it's wieners on top
dude weird's on top i would rather have
that little
nipple pee-pee i think yeah bro imagine
you could tell a girl hey i got the
smallest dick you've ever seen you know
everyone's going to want to see it yeah
you want to come see the complete
opposite of um
stonehenge you know what i'm saying you
want to come see the smallest
you want to see the pebble yeah you're
trying to get this pebble yeah you know
what i'm saying
you got the pebble dick everyone's going
to want to see it oh yeah no one cares
that you're gonna jack off in front of
them
oh in a in a park a squirrel will try to
run up and crack it and get a little
better
venus man i think yeah that's the jam is
that little bitty
dude you could probably do thing you
could do luge or
you know you could probably do like
stuff a lot easier you do anything
really
nice guys the sky's the limit oh you
ride all sorts of bikes don't worry
about your dick hanging out the front
yeah also if you got them uh dick
nipples it's just a nightmare man yeah
it's a nightmare you ain't playing any
sports
can't take your shirt off in the bedroom
nope can't take your shirt off at the
pool dude people are going to try to
throw like um you want to try sucking
your tits
yeah or throw like those little like
frisbees and or those little
you know and get this yeah there's
together to try and win a teddy bear
yeah like try to get him a
stick on your yeah that's a terrible
idea yeah you'd be a [ __ ] carnival
game
nipples i don't want it dude you have to
people would do that thing where they
take little hot dogs if they get a
picture of you and put buns on the
outside of your tits
but i mean it would be fun you know i
think it would be fun it'd be an
interesting life
yeah it'd be an ant but so is having a
pebble dick yeah
but in some countries i think you'd
really be the cat's meow what do people
say
76 said penis-sized nipples
wow wow that's crazy that is insane it
says a lot
but also having a really little wiener
and then nuts behind it would be
crazy ah bro you got them
fat filled up nuts with a little perched
up dick on top
yeah dude looking like a [ __ ] toad
with small eyes
you want toads fill up yeah yeah it
would be like a worm like just kind of
peeking out of an apple yeah i
feel like you're crazy yeah that's
unnecessary i think uh
i think stuart just needs to really kind
of tighten up a little bit i do love
that rat tail though
i like the way he's dressed i think he
needs to tighten up on life though raise
the lower brother
hopefully you figure it out with your
nips uh last one for debate club
coming from jp from kalamazoo oh yeah
michigan i want to come perform up there
yo what up brendan what up theo quick
question
happy post saint patty's better food
quality brick and mortar restaurants
or food trucks gang gang buzz buzz
buzz buzz my red bearded friend buzzy
buzzy buzz
um it's me tough to [ __ ] with brick and
mortar because they're not moving they
have a stationary
they kind of that grill is there it's
part they got a plant they got a plan
with the food with a food truck
it can be chaos they're hit or miss some
amazing you get in and out pretty quick
you walk the streets out with your taco
or churro or
[ __ ] pasta whatever you got or
lobster roll outside that though man
brick and mortar right
yeah you don't want a tornado for a meal
all the goddamn time i like to go sit
down at like a win these are like a
orbeez you know i like to be in there
see who's in there
get to know the locals you know see
who's working see who's resting
the riff fill out a complaint form yeah
yeah trucks you don't have a complaint
for them at the food trucks there's no
you know you got to go around to the
driver's side and [ __ ] kind of knock
on the other window and it's just the
same person
comes over and you're like hey the
[ __ ] you know yeah you might be a
good driver but you're not a good cook
yeah it's very strange it's very good
it's an operation yeah it's really crazy
it's the chef it's customer service it's
pr they're all in the same truck it's
the same person yeah and i don't usually
trust anybody a grill that close to an
emergency break you know what i'm saying
anywhere that you got like
you know with a little you know they
accidentally don't set the break and the
whole [ __ ] restaurant could just
be out of business yeah and there goes
your grilled cheese yeah so i think it's
a little risky and also out of the
trucks they sell a lot of junk you know
it's good stuff but it's like it's
nothing you could raise a baby on
depends what there are some that are
hitters and then some are
terrible some is the worst food you've
ever tried in your life some some of the
best food you ever tried in your life
right now it's the wild west bro yeah
it's still like you and i wanted to open
one we could do it
making [ __ ] mushrooms if we wanted to
yeah you know
what would we call it i wonder if we did
a food truck spicy bros
no i see brothers pasta pisces bros pies
pp it's pbp
okay nice try yeah you're right still
you know what i'm saying i shouldn't
have corrected you man but it's my
birthday if it was still your birthday i
wouldn't let you say
i appreciate it bro it is your birthday
you do whatever i see brothers pies dude
yeah [ __ ] just hitting them cold
slices out the door boy
yeah them [ __ ] just thin new york
slices
new york style pie yeah we don't [ __ ]
with the thick crust
uh-uh that [ __ ] we don't [ __ ] want
that graham cracker those vegan hitters
yeah yeah
something healthy for somebody you know
it's pizza so don't [ __ ] it up though
you know they got
crab cake it's not pizza i'm talking
actual pie oh you wanna make like cherry
pie and [ __ ] yeah or say piscey brothers
pizza then if it's pizza
well no because the people in the know
call pizza pies bro
yeah dude a couple people do pisces bros
pies and where we got
[ __ ] we got sausage
pepperoni meat lovers what do you want
bro you want cheese you want that
margarita we got
it bro we got it whoa bro
we got that theo crazy bread that theo
crazy bread
put a little [ __ ] devil's dandruff on
a little crater
a little kratom crust yeah kratom crust
that deep dish kratom crust
that kratom cracker crust bro that
should be fire
dude that would be pretty cool to have
uh maybe like a creatine filled doughnut
i can sell those
that'd be dope it would be cool to have
something that's like sweet but also has
that kind of power lifters vibe somebody
that's about to you know
just really just hit the gym you know
yeah just put a bunch of caffeine in a
[ __ ]
yeah a pizza roll yeah i love that man
wow another bad idea
what did they say 62 percent of the fans
said food trucks [ __ ] that
no if you got the right food truck
though i can vouch for that that [ __ ] is
delicious well what is the difference
between postmates and
it's all like it's just like how close
do you want the food
how fast you want to get it yeah how
fast you want to get it and usually the
faster it is
the less good it is depends if some
restaurants take forever like you got a
steakhouse you're there for seven hours
really no one has that time yeah it's
dark
you gotta talk to people wait to be
seated it's loud
but you can order something that could
be healthy for you you get a food truck
it's like [ __ ] what do we got here
it's one place it's like sometimes they
got that persian [ __ ] roadster out
there it's just two persian dudes
selling [ __ ] dirty beef out of the
back you know yeah
you can find an armenian food truck just
selling hair oh yeah
i think they're shaving each other in
the back yeah dude that reminds me of
speaking we had honey boo on earlier one
of my favorite episodes was when they
went to the wig shop and the name of the
wig place was called
shh it's a wig no way yeah that's
so dope that's so cause wigs are those
secret tops bro yeah wigs no one wants
to know you have a whey guy
dude once you have a wig unless you have
cancer if you have cancer and you want
to have a wig for that you know that
comfortability and you know to be less
aerodynamic and that makes sense
but if you're just wigging you know that
[ __ ] is
that's just embarrassing because then
all you're doing is trying to pretend
like you don't have a wig on
yeah that's your whole that's your whole
agenda for the day
is that you don't get found out like
you're a russian spy in america
that you have a wig on like it consumes
your life you're right bro dude your
whole life is just like hey do i look
like i have a wig on her whole life is
hoping a
[ __ ] gust of wind doesn't hit your
day to [ __ ] your whole world up
it is so weird wigs dude we should
definitely learn more have you ever seen
when two girls get a fight and someone
has a wig
yeah yeah classy you've seen those kids
that do the prank on instagram where
they grab someone's wig and runs off
oh dude classic dangerous that sounds
like dangerous
yeah people kill over wigs dude okay
what else do we got here
it's that does it for debate club it's
time for rip my drip
first up we got raina
what's the deal with her man rip my drip
huh
well first of all those ovaries that she
has printed on the dress what is that
yeah it's either ovaries or a calzone of
some sort
yeah it looks like something that was in
the microwave for too long dude yeah it
looks like a totino's pizza gone wrong
yeah bro now that's kind of sexy imagine
if a girl yeah
had a skirt with a couple totino's pizza
rolls hanging off the side of it
let them cool off too oh but bite into
one of them and burn your [ __ ] lips
first every time
every time every time bro dude they
could all be frozen
there's that one that's [ __ ] just
like [ __ ] assassin that [ __ ]
that's chuck norris of [ __ ] totino's
pizza rolls that [ __ ] showed up ready
to go dude when's that look at this
little pizza pocket once i made a pizza
pocket
oh yeah and then i tried going pizza
lean get the [ __ ] out of my face too the
lean pockets
and they were just smaller yeah it was
half of a pizza pop
and it comes that little coffin and i
still ate two of them yeah
pizza pockets were good man yeah shout
out to pizza pockets and pizza
positories have you ever had those bro i
haven't you're on the run bro and you
need a [ __ ]
you need that pizza oh you want that oh
you want that uh
that the works thin crust you just shove
one of those pizza depositories in your
butt
all right it's straight through the
whole it's like the meat lovers
and yeah after if you belch a couple
times you can taste the pizza a little
oh damn
yeah all right pretty cool speaking of
meat lovers um
so it looks like she has a very
basic girl's room i will say that i've
i've
been in a similar type of bedroom
probably 70 times
me too about 38 times i'll tell you
right now that dresser
not reliable yeah i think you don't
think that thing will fall break at any
given moment now the dresser looks
possibly inherited
from somewhere haunted if anything it
could be haunted i could see the bottom
drawer having a couple of former pieces
i'll tell you this
you uh hit that [ __ ] drip drip
pizza pocket right that stuff on the
walls falling down
oh wow you're getting after that that
stuff on the wall that [ __ ]
uh dream catcher or nightmare catcher
whatever the [ __ ] that is that's oh yeah
that's a [ __ ] little hope tapestry
i'll tell you this dude that
well that thing will definitely stay up
if i'm [ __ ] bro i'm that lowkey
[ __ ]
you you you look like a vegan i'm the
quiet [ __ ] i'm the emphysema of sex
dude you know you're saying nobody
everybody no one knows what's going on
oh nobody yeah look like this i do that
lays down and gets [ __ ]
oh yeah and then smoked a cigarette oh
i'll smoke an invisible cigarette dude
you just lay there while she's like you
good oh yeah and just complain about
that yeah complain about that
she walks up and takes a piss oh yeah my
yeah i'm just looking
at you oh very low key i don't mind
sleeping before sex either actually
that's one of my moles
you like the rest let's just rest yeah
let me get that rest dude
watching two episodes of dateline
together just as good as [ __ ] i think
now you see you getting older bro yeah
it's all
good yeah that's true so
next up for rip my drip well you look
nice though i want to say that so
that's about tabitha raina
rhino yeah yeah now from bowling green
bro is she
oh wow it's a mental health facility uh
next up we've got
taj now big taj obviously opens and
opened up a bootleg
pharmacy in his [ __ ] living room yeah
yeah obviously taj sells [ __ ]
perfume on the weekends out of his car
yeah and it looks like he got some in
his eyes too rotaj's
his beard and his chest just one
continued piece tasha has definitely
repurposed a little bit of local hair
for sure uh or his bush has just grown
all the way up to his neck bro you gotta
tie it i think it's one i think he has a
one piece
it's a one-piece hairpiece some people
have that some people's grandparents
grew up in very cold areas and they
they'll have full body families full
body hair on the family i mean i can't
even tell the necklace it looks like it
you know
like good looking dude yeah seem like a
handsome guy he's got that uh
scarf un-iron pants i [ __ ] respect
that dude
the [ __ ] it pants yeah [ __ ] it dude
what's up with those bracelets
zoom in on the watching bracelets for me
what's up with the chain
what are we doing here he's got those
little bangladeshi hitters right there
okay
yeah he does and those could be his or
those could be keepsakes from crime
mm-hmm
the middle east rings you never know
these days man it's a dangerous time
look at that stolen china in the back
yeah you know that china's not yours bro
unless you unless he lives with his
grandma
and ain't the last dude you knew under
80 years old with china go
that ain't his or he stole it or he's
robbing this house
and went quick i'm a fan of king of the
sting take my pick
yeah let me rip my drip real quick while
i steal this old lady's [ __ ]
yeah feel my steel what's it called send
this into him
you know take my china jesus man
okay thank you for tuning into yeah you
seem like a healthy man hopefully you
got away clean right now
looks healthy nice uh posture last one
from nova scotia this is cj hamilton
damn
darius rucker bro uh darius
rufford um
what was this why you whatever that's
derek
the dolphins make me cry that's him
right hooting the blowfish yeah dude
that's him right there
i heard if you find dearest rucker and
you yell out hootie he freaks the [ __ ]
out bro because he's darius rucker now
he's killing cups yeah i can see that
that's
rogan go back to that dude man that's
fro rogan right there bro
dude he looks like all sorts of fun his
pants are so tight that's james hardly
look at this dude man but i love he's
got that hawaii hitter on
he's got that chest meat showing out now
he's a total opposite of sweet taj that
just sent in that jpeg but
yeah he is he's a smooth seal he's a
smoothie if you don't have any chest
hair
zero he's the exact opposite look how
slick i bet you couldn't keep a drop of
water on his chest right
you ain't holding him down oh god dude
forget about it phil
oh you put butter on that guy you'll
never [ __ ] hug him he he's just i
mean look how smooth he is
and uh i'm not mad at the fanny pack
it's pretty filled up though
well you're karen i have no idea yeah
that thing looks a little yeah you gotta
you gotta take some items out of that
fanny pack it's too thick bro you got
too much [ __ ] to carry in there
you need a backpack if you got to keep
that much stuff yeah or just tie the
fanny pack onto your back or sew it onto
the back of a shirt
yeah that's a good point good looking
dude though not matt the outfit not mad
at the chain
pretty confident at his mom's house no
socks on yeah shout out to this dude
now that's the giveaway though is you
got the style but you got to get a house
or a place of your own
you got to get some respect for yourself
can you get your socks on in your mom's
house taking pictures
you're too comfortable you're too
comfortable yeah you're comfortable man
watching reruns of family ties get out
yeah get out to the world bro
get out in the world start a food truck
see what you could see yes pisces bros
pie
yeah get out there
what else we got that does it for rip my
drip next up
king it or sting it all right let's get
into this
dude i tell you man the first one comes
from
angel dust is that still around dude god
i'd take us some
yeah it's your birthday i wish somebody
would accidentally [ __ ] inject
something to me
yeah i wouldn't mind some this comes
from deacon from vegas
greetings from rainy las vegas gangang
buzz buzz yeah got king or sting it for
you king it or sting it
nipple rings on hot chicks see me let me
know what you think guys or
dudes well uh conor mcgregor
going through a tough week first of all
he's had too much uh prophet 26 or
whatever it is what is it uh
proper problem but i'll say this gang
gang to you brother and that's one of
our armenian brothers right there or he
could be
german uh not armenian let's hear him
again
i'd probably say he is straight from uh
dublin
from las vegas oh las vegas that's a las
vegas accent
and what was his question he wants to
know about
buzz king or sing it for you king can
oh [ __ ] king it dude
bro my thing is too dude a lot of times
i'll give a girl a key to my apartment
just put it right on that nipple ring
dude yeah i'll leave my [ __ ] garage
door opener on that deck yeah i don't i
trust a girl as a nipple
oh yeah she's down for the cause if i
release them tits and their parents i
think
we about to get wild oh yeah and you see
them nipple rings and some sometimes
you'll have a girl she's a janitor she's
got like 30 keys on one of the nipples
it's just all dudes
[ __ ] keys and it doesn't matter
here's the thing though
if you if you're getting hot and heavy
with a girl and you unrelease them
[ __ ] one two tits and you see some
nipples it'd be like show up to your
friend's house he opens the garage
with two motorcycles and a bag full of
coke oh you're getting wild bro
you're getting wild dude you know it's
gonna be a wild night
oh yeah and sometimes you'll see a girl
maybe in miami or somewhere exotic
ecuador
where they'll walk their dog they'll
have a chain going from the dog to their
tit you know where you can have your tit
out even more so
[ __ ] baffling bro yeah and that's
when i throw that frisbee and watch that
thing [ __ ] perk out
yeah you know yeah bro yeah yeah so
we're all four nipples yeah i'm saying
for that dude
yeah me too thank you thank you sir
good question bro next up
mary king it hi guys
love you love your podcast kingdom sting
the father and the kid this past weekend
we listen to you we stream you
thank you mary it's become our new
obsession but enough of the ass kissing
let's get down to business jesus clean
it or sing it
lip injections
love you that's buzz buzz girl wow
stinks thing was kind of cool sting
sting is pretty cool
sting sting rolls off your tongue
doesn't it yeah gang gang sting sting
buzz buzz buzz buzz kind of delay it
kind of [ __ ] everything up
buzz buzz i don't know buzz buzz stink
sting
sting sting gang gang drip drip um
lip injections listen man from my
experience i'm a fan
yeah i'm a fan dude ass kylie jenner how
her lips are doing
she went she's a dope ass girl now
before she had nothing
her lips didn't exist she goes to the
kim k doctors
now she's a smoke show found her a man
found her a rapper
sure he's cheating on her at least she
got one yeah she's got one in the
[ __ ] web you know what i'm trying
she wouldn't do that anything's possible
through lip injections thank god
you know what i'm saying that's true now
if you definitely look at that
dumb ass on the left lips from the lord
now look at her on the right
first of all on the left that's a
nine-year-old child that's a
nine-year-old man but look what the
doctor did on the right
yeah but she looks too artificial for me
i'm scared about how she's gonna look in
three years she's gonna start to look uh
remember when you have a pool toy and
you leave it on the sun over the summer
and like
later in the summer you're like oh man
it's that thing this was yellow now it's
a
bronze yeah it's bronzed and it's
flattened a little bit and you don't
know what's going on yeah you know what
i did
took that [ __ ] back to the store and had
it working as well and then it came back
even better that's what you can do with
these girls with their tits their face
their mouth
even asses well we had a guy bus did
pool toy repair dude it's not a big
business that was the problem no it's
not booming but yeah i say lip
injections i say no
it's just even if you have nothing
though even if you have that little
twizzler for an upper lip
i'd rather see that [ __ ] lester holt
you know and lester hold if you was a
real
crime hunter you'd [ __ ] track down
your upper lip daddy
and i'll [ __ ] say that i think i've
said it before oh but lester
has zero upper lip holy [ __ ] bro yeah
you don't tell me he'd look a thousand
times better with two lips
with two lips like he only has one like
someone bit off the top
yeah like he was with some [ __ ] in the
early 90s she bit off his top lip
oh yeah with shamwow's ex-girlfriend it
looks like he had a little bit of maybe
too much coke one time that [ __ ]
heart hit her
and chomped his own ripped it off
himself yeah thought it was foot yeah
that front piece i just feel like gotta
have some lips bro that [ __ ] top soft
bumper i don't think you have anything
heavy though dude if you kiss a girl
that have those
injections it's like uh
it's like trying to eat a piece of hard
sushi no no not if you do it right
you're talking about that eel no not if
you do it right though man if you do it
right you go to a good doctor
they look good man they look neat
i'll say that they look cool they look
they remind you of like you've been with
a girl
with a fake ass like a brazilian ass
where they put in the fat no not the
what is that awesome is it this is me
awesome
i've seen some fake ass that haven't
aged very well though and like some of
that starts to go out on the side or the
legs
exception bro for the go to miami i was
just in miami fake ass is
everywhere really best time in your life
how much is a fake ass you think
30 40 g's jesus no i have no idea
i'd get half of it and just you know
have that side walk by that side with
the guys
you could do that just stay on one side
just walk that same street
yeah you could do that all right next
one this comes from the self-broke
self-proclaimed lot lizard king
hell yeah
brandon theo
what do you think bros gang bang
because yeah
um snow that's a good one
listen i grew up in the snow did you i
grew up in denver in the snow and you
can [ __ ] keep it bro did you hear
that
yellow snow yeah i grew up in the snow
you ever had yellow snow no it's dirty
yeah people pissing in it yeah i could
see that but there's so much more snow
you could go by
you'd be surprised people just piss
everywhere in the snow i've never seen
anything like that never been to denver
uh i have been in denver um recently
i mean i'm sure people have pissed
throughout time so i don't think were
you there in the 90s
nope so there we go so um i think uh
a big notice now yeah i think snow it's
annoying it's cold
it looks it looks pretty when it first
falls then give it
an hour or two and the cars and people
walking looks into [ __ ]
but snow i think is that excitement it's
like free excitement just out of the sky
you know it reminds you that you live in
on a
plane that occasionally where you know
some higher power drops snow on you you
know it's like it reminds you that
you know you get free excitement you get
to make a snowman you get to get out of
school when you're young you get to get
you throw snow at somebody then they
throw it harder at you
yeah you learn a lesson a snowball fight
bro this is the thing
you know how you say snow days do you
know what type of
[ __ ] we had to go through to get a snow
day i mean
it would have to be a [ __ ] category
seven blizzard yeah we used to have to
go through some [ __ ]
they wouldn't they would never cancel it
man really no it's exhausting for
everyone involved but you need to learn
what huh you learn why great questions
while you stayed at home
with your mom i had to go to school and
learn other [ __ ]
dude i had to bike to school five miles
kicking crocodiles away from my feet
huge mosquitoes
one time a mosquito picked me up and
took me to a different school picked me
right up off my bike that's the movie of
jumanji bro
[Music]
well i'll say this dude what was the
guy's question this guy's a trucker bro
this guy's obviously done some
dude he's the lot lizard king yeah
that's for sure sure
bro dude imagine getting smell on the
[ __ ] feeling the rumble of that truck
and getting a sweet hummer at the same
time now that is god
oh god that is god u.s of a all the way
damn boy dude i would pour gasoline out
of the window while i drive if i was
driving a big truck like
that i would drink mountain dude red
just [ __ ] mountain dew code red
and just [ __ ] all the lot lizards if i
was him yeah i just have a whole [ __ ]
slurpee machine in the back of my chair
man and just get my dicks up
all over the nation oh yeah i'd pull
into montana
i'd go all over vermont vermont you bet
your ass when you get my [ __ ] licked
in new hampshire
wow yeah bro i'm having clam chowder in
boston while getting sucked up
jesus dude what's up bro you've got some
gumbo in new orleans yeah man walking
sucked off in a truck
you're right you're right god bro that's
what i'm saying this guy's living the
dream
we're the suckers in here if he has a
gun he is
if he doesn't uh what's he doing he's
the lizard king bro that's true he
probably has at least a
38. i would say this man i think snow
is great i think it's you know i don't
have to deal with it as much so i know
that some people have a tough time
but it shuts down the interstate which
gives you a chance to meet other people
instead of having to just drive by them
all the time
i think um snow gives you a chance to
stay home from work sometimes i fell
down in the snow
um you're slipped on black eyes still
yeah actually i slept a couple weeks
because i still have a cut on my leg
from it
where did you slip in black eyes new
york city all right that's fair uh dude
that [ __ ] is so slippery running across
the street and i was like oh that's
this it's kind and eight
kids i would pay so much money to have
that [ __ ] footage
but reminder it's so bad it reminds you
that how like
[ __ ] if that was a little worse i could
have died you're like no here's the
thing if you were a little
older you would have broke your head oh
you're dead oh you're breaking your hip
snow kills old people all the time dude
and look here's the thing old people are
great
until they're not you know until they
get hurt and you gotta [ __ ]
hear them complain in the hospital for
the rest of their life dude it's a
[ __ ] lo
look it it thins the herd a little bit
and we need snow every now and then a
couple old people you know they head to
heaven off that [ __ ] snow slip
so and that's how it works the plants
need melted snow
water so i say king it i say [ __ ] snow
and that does it for you that's
interesting king it or sting it
it's time for some relationship advice
and just a reminder you can send your
relationship
questions to kingdomstingit gmail.com we
need some more of these let these two
guys help you out
ladies let the experts help you out bro
let the one two piscey bro experts help
you out man yeah dude
he's you know [ __ ] imaginary lot
lizards and i'm lonely so
let's figure this [ __ ] out people we got
you the first one up comes from briggs
great name briggs meyer to make
toothbrushes
hey king in the sting it's break from
utah
wow just chilling coming back from
university
the you anyway i got a relationship
advice question for you guys why is he
looking around
so i've been dating this girl for a
couple of months
she is uh four years
fresh off the boat from china she's that
authentic
chinese oh yeah why'd you look at cat
sweetie anyway
it's been danny for a while and it's
been going really good
but last uh last weekend
i told her that i think i like her i
kind of dig her
and she didn't really reciprocate so i
was kind of she didn't speak english
[Music]
and the next morning she texts me
and it turns out she's 33 years old hey
man brother i'm only 24. so that's a
nine year difference
so it's like a really big difference
yeah
i guess my question is what do you guys
think about uh
run bro big age gap she's a spy
are they okay
you [ __ ] figured it out report to
authorities
dude you figured it out you know long
fbi have to [ __ ]
do work to [ __ ] catch these chinese
spies
and she opens up to you you know why she
didn't understand what you said
shouldn't speak [ __ ] english bro
that's why
run bro she's 33 in chinese years
yeah you know how old yao ming was when
he came here he was 67
and we just figured it out if your girl
says she's 33
she's 72 years old and she's a spy
well she definitely seems like someone
that's interested in you though
i'll say that you know she's you know
she came over here
i wonder where they met i guess online
probably and she came over here to see
you
i think you got to at least give her a
couple months to see how it plays out
i mean also how do you not have an idea
maybe that somebody's 33
you know no we talked about this chinese
people you cannot tell yeah
like benefit the doubt there he probably
looked at her like damn she's young as
[ __ ] she's at university with me too
yeah she's there infiltrating to be a
college student
yeah and obviously honey [ __ ] you into
being her man
and when you go oh i think i love you
and she's like
she's done no [ __ ] english bro you're
that little white [ __ ]
treat brother you know that little soy
snack
you're a small piece in this [ __ ]
clock but i'll chinese clock treat it
with respect man cause the chinese they
don't give a [ __ ] dude
i should jack you up with their feet
they kill you they come back as a dragon
they come back as a lamb they come back
as a [ __ ] anything they want
as another chinese person dude the
reincarnation wheel
in of being chinese spins so much faster
i hear that the holding tank if you die
as of just a white guy
it's [ __ ] 10 to 12 years to get back
into exactly chinese
dude you're working at a factory in a
[ __ ] year and a half making ipads
yeah or eye patches uh let's go abroad
let's go to our consultant cat what do
you think about this
since you may know these people
well i don't know i do know
over in asia we are much more sexually
like repressed
talk about stuff like that she is older
she's here
i mean even though but yeah
but i don't think he was like yo i'm
telling you my dick sucked tonight after
class
i think he was like hey i think i'm
really into you we should get
a bite and she just ran off how do they
view that in different that age gap
dating
in other places do you think oh yeah you
never really see an old like japanese
dude with a young
japanese girl well i know in china
specifically
there are more guys trying to they're
trying to get more guys to date girls
because so many parents wanted boys so
during the one child policy a lot of
people kept the sons and gave away the
girl
so now there's a big gap in girl to guy
ratio it's a real [ __ ] fest out there
yeah
so why did she come here you think does
she maybe she likes white guys is that a
new thing
maybe a lot of asian girls you like
white guys wow
dude this whole tunis huh there's this
ho don't touch me dude
a couple [ __ ] pisces bros gangbang
dang
because cuz bro um so good luck out
there man at least you're in utah it's a
beautiful place good luck to utah state
and the ncaa tournament and it's
you yeah it seemed like you have a
chance brother uh i'd be careful though
man what tread lightly with this one
yeah she's obviously hiding something
more than just uh
her feelings for you yeah i think she's
a spy that bichon frise bro all right
uh and the second and last one for
relationship
questions comes from ali oh ali
ali hi guys it's oli here from england
i'm just wondering about a little bit of
advice from you um
so basically sometimes i like working
out
and going to the gym no way am i bros
more than i like having relations with
my girlfriend oh you're gay bro
is this bad let me know not at all you
gay man
and there's nothing wrong with you you
think that he is uh if you would
rat hold on beautiful now listen he's a
good looking dude yeah looks fit right
congrats tight little s girl he has in
his head there this is all good
looks like a straight character out of
[ __ ] metal gear solid yeah fantastic
listen if you would there's not i love
you
i love most my friends if i could rather
[ __ ] a hot
girl than lift weights with my bros i'm
picking the girl
99.9 of the time well that's
old-fashioned thinking i think i think
look man
the gym is going to be there yeah but
it's not going to be there at the time
that all your buddies can go
and maybe somebody has a [ __ ] sack of
fresh chicken cutlets afterwards you
guys can grill up and [ __ ] make fun
of each other
i think you have some of those
opportunities man fucking's kind of old
school dude
people that are you know it's like
you know we get it we [ __ ] you know so
it's like
i used to do that in college man i'd
rather go sometimes with my with my
buddies over to the rec
center and do the weights and go get the
um meal plan after that and get that
unlimited uh pudding so they had all
kind of good stuff over there so look i
feel you man
but i think you you just don't want to
disrespect your girlfriend that you do
it all the time i think you want to make
some time for her
but i didn't like to you know ejaculate
because
i didn't want to um
uh not have any power at the gym i'd
have more power if i had more uh
seed in me yeah if you had that [ __ ]
flowing through the veins the thing is
too i mean listen
maybe he's not gay maybe and i will say
this yeah give him a chance
i wouldn't well hear me out here i'm
gonna defend him here i would
much rather hang out with my bros i'd
much rather hang with my bros
if we're just hanging out for a good
time i have more in common with my bros
i do a girl
yeah or my girl you know it's like i'm
right
you know all right yeah
so years dude
you just come home and you're [ __ ]
pissed and then your family
all your kids leave to go [ __ ] be in
woodstock yeah so i'm going to say this
man i think if you got to do what you
got to do trust your instincts dude it
doesn't mean you're a homoerotic guy
and even if you are bro who cares you're
a handsome guy you could probably [ __ ]
one of your buddies if you want
dude you guys could deadlift all day and
[ __ ] each other at night
yeah you do that they do that at [ __ ]
24 hour fitness in west hollywood
it's a package you pay for but it's yeah
but it's look if you want to just treat
your girl right
make sure that if you go get something
for dinner get her one did he say
he has a girl though or did he say he'd
rather hang out with the dudes than
girls
than his girl i think all right well
mape's the wrong girl but also
maybe you've been with her for a while
she's boring as [ __ ] so of course you
want to hang out with yourself she
sounds so nice man i thought she sounded
like a nice girl well he didn't give us
any info
i need more info on him yeah but he's a
handsome dude maybe he wants a [ __ ]
power clean suck
what else we got that does it for
relationship advice send those in to
king
king and sting gmail.com it's time for
the last segment
before i start my heart and it's flop my
aunt
this was sent in by christopher
this is his aunt mariah well i know what
theo got for his birthday a boner
dang a little bit of a boner i used
actually masturbation last night so
oh yeah yeah first time in a while yeah
the tubing still works and everything
yeah were you exhausted uh just yeah i
probably shouldn't have done it
why not i don't know you told yourself
uh
no i just was kind of just i don't know
i was like
upset and then ended up just jerking off
so
but mariah seemed like a nice person
this is actually on chloe sent in from
jason okay aunt chloe
dude chloe is a i'm sorry is that
jasmine from aladdin
yeah good god man chloe seems like a
nice person i would love to
say hi and she looks nice and yellow
a little red bag that she has matches
her shoes she looks kind of fancy though
that would be my only concern
yeah she looks like she might be uh
you know you're not gonna take her to
the cheesecake factory she might
expect a little more than that here's
the thing homeboy who was saying you'd
rather
lift with his bros and hang out with
this girl yeah does your girl look like
this
because then gabriel well i don't know
bro sometimes a fancy girl you be around
him so much and they just keeps talking
about something
and you don't know what they're saying
and you feel like you need to go home i
feel you
it's like you don't even speak the same
language yeah yeah it's like she's a lot
lizard and you're just like dude you're
too much
dude then the lot has ferraris in it bro
cause this [ __ ] ain't getting into a
damn honda civic
oh she's the gecko of the lizard she's
that colorful gecko
you know those cute geckos you're like
goddamn she'll save you 15
on your car insurance fashion faux show
uh beautiful aunt man thanks for sending
her in
she's a smoky slizzard yeah if you want
any um
you know neat if she you guys need
nieces or nephews in the family let me
know
yeah if you need some genetics let me
know yeah i'm with you genetics dude
well well yeah
okay if you want kids have the body of
kermit the frog i'll send theo over
okay what do we got next up this is
aunt heather from michael salazar now
i'm gonna tell you this right now
heather if you're listening or her
family's listening
get her a nap really so i'm gonna say
get her a nap
right now she looks tired she's [ __ ]
exhausted she does look tired but i'll
say those beautiful smiles she's
obviously from slovenia
or i would also say poland
or um she she looks like maybe she was
sent a sexy pic after full
the entire family's laundry yes she does
she's having a [ __ ] affair on the
side
and sent this pic she's heartwarming she
seems like a woman that's heartwarming
this is the kind of woman that
uh that cares about you man she's got
that you know
she'll wash the [ __ ] stains at your
undies and make you stroganoff yeah
that's what she looks like oh she's got
the soft
no complaints are you talking about the
softies yeah she got the soft hair
sugar baby hitters but i like that this
is the kind of woman that loves you man
loves
you first beautiful aunt misha what's
her name
it is aunt heather heather oh just
heather
nothing so they might be from michigan
you know they might be from green bay
hudson falls new york ooh close still a
bay hudson bay
close shout out to her and seriously if
you're listening
warm glass of milk in a nap now yeah
maybe take
it eight hours or just sleep for days or
take a r yeah relax a little i'll see
you at a meeting i bet she seems like a
woman that i know from the around the
room
again i'm sticking with she makes a mean
beef stroganoff what else you got yeah
last one for flaw my aunt this is aunt
mariah from christopher
what is go and where's she at
connecticut probably somewhere
down to heaven where they didn't say
paradise
jesus persia you ain't dealing with a
boner now
mariah don't [ __ ] touch him touch me
pisces
my birthday spicy breathe boner bros um
god damn that's somebody's aunt dude
dude i would have been a nephew forever
if my aunt looked like that i didn't
think i had a [ __ ] ant i was just
jerking off to nobody
yeah my aunts don't look like that
dude if i had an aunt like that i'd
breastfeed off the whole family yeah
definitely feet off that ant and only
that end beautiful land she seems like
um
is she schooled is she education
uh i was i would say so with that pose
and just
you know the nice bronze skin she
screams to me
degrees blue nail polish that screams to
me
geds because the blue yeah
she looks like a fancy la lizard man
yeah she looks [ __ ] risky too man she
got us sitting on a nice bathtub that is
an expensive bathtub so that's either at
a hotel room or if that's at her house
well i'm priced out of the scenario
already so that's that's
above my price point this young lady i'd
fly that aunt first class
wow yeah i'm there right now there you
go man there you go shout out to that
finance aunt yeah you got a nice aunt
there she definitely
you know i don't know she seems pretty
hot
that does it for this week's flaw my
aunt going forward with your submissions
for your for your aunts or relatives
send in a couple facts about them let's
let's get some info on them that we can
know about i need to know what she does
for work her
address social security number pretend
your cell phone number
creating a dating profile for him give
him yeah yeah
give us a little info on this girl but
that does it for flaw my aunt it's it's
time to wrap it up with uh what inspired
you guys this week
let's get to start my heart that thai
ass ant
inspired me to take a nap i know i feel
nappy i think it was those donuts a cat
no it's don't blame the donuts that i am
bro
um let's see here start my heart this
week
would go to deontay wilder because
in the world of professional boxing
which is a nightmare of a world for
professional sports
everyone's just bouncing to the highest
bidder and just playing whatever
i'll get 100 million here but i'm going
to fight scrubs because it's best for
this promoter
and when showtime put all this money
behind a young deontay wilder and built
his name and got him where he's at
and he had those same offers he decided
to stick with show
time and ride it out because he's a
loyal ass dude which doesn't happen in
sports very often
so mine's deante wilder shout out to
deontay wilder i respect that man
i'm gonna go with that vernal
i'm gonna go with him mother nature
mother nature really started my heart
this week they got that vernal equinox
and that's tomorrow
so it's a real special time when
you know basically mother nature does
whatever her you know
she basically turns into david blaine
it's in the northern hemisphere in the
southern hemisphere
and it is awesome so if you want to be a
part of something special
i'm saying mother nature people always
you know slipping on this [ __ ] saying
oh she don't do this you sound like the
worst
[ __ ] earth science teacher in the
world describing what's happening right
now
okay deontay wilder dude you ever heard
of him
you just went ma took my hardest
earth earth because they're natural
cause spring is coming and flowers are
booming well you try to do spring you
can't even [ __ ] get your act together
dude spring is when you take something
that's all beaten down by winter and
make it [ __ ] pop again
and the only lady out there doing that
bad [ __ ] work
is [ __ ] mother nature vernal equinox
she got the solstices and another
equinox later in the year this [ __ ] is
busy
okay getting the bees to buzz and the
flowers to [ __ ]
dude and nobody else does it like this
bad [ __ ] right there
[ __ ] mother nature shout out to
mother nature thank you
it's your birthday man it is man it's my
birthday dude i'm going to carmax i'm
[ __ ] trading my car
get rid of your car yeah you're sick of
it huh yeah just start walking
everywhere it hurts my back i
i mean i love walking i love walking too
it's just too hard here to even cross
the street people get pissed
oh my god it's a nightmare yeah dude get
a scooter
be the grown man on a scooter i thought
about it yeah i know i don't want to
take your
stilo though nah i don't really [ __ ]
with them anymore really
not really have you seen your instagram
problem i haven't been on one you won't
see one on there anymore
that's okay yeah bro we'll see you dance
we're gonna keep up bro i'm keeping up
man all right
well happy birthday to me happy birthday
to the
king master himself yep the rag
was your birthday it was yesterday bro
remember pisces bros pies oh yes
[ __ ] dude too bad it was yesterday man
nobody is almost over though we just
celebrate so you're just kind of over
now too though
it's just getting started you know what
i'm saying i feel you bro
i'll be in milwaukee this weekend friday
saturday milwaukee turner hall baby get
it wow i'll be in san jose and then i'll
be in phoenix next weekend
next week i'm in uh washington dc dc
improv
all those shows are more sold out get
them tpackay.com
uh dude for reals happy birthday man
gang thank you man happy belated
birthday to you
those buzz
is